- [David] Hello readers.
I just got back from
the library with these.
Books.
"Oh, big surprise," you say.
I went to the library.
I found two books.
No, I get it, but these
books will help us talk
about the difference between a
first and secondhand account.
You see, this is a travel
diary written by a young man
on the Oregon Trail like 150 years ago.
Whereas this is a book
about the Oregon Trail
written last year.
A firsthand account is
created by the person
who experienced an event.
Firsthand accounts are also
called primary sources.
Primary is another way
to say first or original.
It uses pronouns like I or me.
It's told from one person's perspective.
A secondhand account is
more distant from the event,
like a book or a newspaper article.
The author wasn't there but they used
firsthand accounts like interviews,
diaries, photos, or video recordings
to stitch the story together.
The story uses pronouns
like they, she, or he,
not I or we.
Let me show you more
specifically by comparing
these two passages.
Okay, so this one, our firsthand account,
comes from "The Diary of Horace Griggs",
our young migrant on the Oregon Trail.
"July 18th, 1871.
"We're in the Wyoming territory now,
"and it's been a few days
since we had good water.
"I'm starting to worry.
"It's been at least a week since any of us
"saw a tree.
"But the buffalo chips remain plentiful.
"At least the darn things burn hot."
And here's the excerpt
from a secondary source,
our book about the Oregon Trail
that came out last year.
"The Oregon Trail didn't have many trees.
"The pioneers used buffalo chips,
"dried buffalo dung,
"as fuel for their fires.
"In fact, some children played
games with buffalo chips.
"they tossed them around like Frisbees."
So we've got here two passages
both about buffalo droppings,
good job me.
Let me be clear.
It's not gross.
They're mostly made of
dried grass, honestly.
What are the big differences
between these two passages?
Look at how Horace uses
first person pronouns
like I, or we, or us.
He's telling the story
from his perspective
and the perspective of other
people traveling with him.
It's like he's telling us a story.
And it's his story to tell.
He was right there starting
fires with buffalo chips.
We can see how he felt about
not having access to water.
He was worried.
Firsthand accounts connect us more closely
with the emotions of the writer.
And because he was there,
he can accurately describe
his experiences.
However, this guy can only describe
his own experience
He doesn't know what it was
like in other wagon trains.
like to be a Native community
encountering these settlers.
He's writing from one perspective,
and it's his perspective.
Now look at the second passage.
It uses the pronouns their and they
to refer to the pioneers and their kids.
What does that tell us?
The writer is not part of the group,
wasn't there, doesn't consider themselves
part of the us the way that
Horace considers himself
part of an us.
The author is more distant.
It's not the author's individual story.
Instead, they're trying
to tell the stories
of other people through research.
This is what makes it a secondary source,
a secondhand account.
Because secondhand
accounts are more distant
from the events they describe,
they're usually less emotional.
The author of this second
passage, for example,
isn't worried about
anything that's happening
to the pioneers.
They're not even referring to
a specific set of pioneers.
They're talking about what
these migrants did in general.
They're giving you background
knowledge, general knowledge.
That kind of distance lets the author
of a secondhand account cover more ground.
They don't have to stick to the narrative
of one family or one person,
or even one moment in time.
First and secondhand
accounts are both important.
When I was a kid, they used to advertise
sugary cereals as part
of a balanced breakfast.
Little bowl of sugary
cereal, a glass of milk,
a bowl of fruit, maybe
a sausage, some toast.
Well, think of primary
and secondary sources
as part of a balanced information diet.
A little of column A,
a little of column B.
You just gotta take your knowledge spoon
and dig in deep into
your perspectives bowl.
That's a thing that I made up just now.
Diversity of perspectives
does a body good.
You can learn anything.
David out.